mardi dernier Olivia se promenait près
de chez elle lorsqu'elle a aperçu deux
hélicoptères biélorusse qui survolaient
le territoire polonais à très basse
altitude du jamais vu à cette frontière
ultra sécurisée Olivia n'en revient
toujours pas
on pourrait penser qu'avec une telle
présence de force de sécurité c'était
hélicoptère a survolé au moins certaines
d'entre elles ces hélicoptères ont volé
très bas on pouvait très bien voir leur
drapeau biélorus et leurs étoiles rouges
et plusieurs milliers d'officients en
uniformes n'ont pourtant pas fait usage
de leur jours
l'incident inquiète aussi la Lituanie
avec les mouvements du groupe Wagner et
une crise migratoire à sa propre
frontière avec la Biélorussie la
situation a provoqué cette rencontre
entre le président lituanien et le
Premier ministre polonais
aucun doute là-dessus
déployez nos unités militaires ici
renforcer notre ligne de défense y
compris par des fortifications physiques
c'est précisément ce qui va protéger nos
citoyens
la Pologne et la Lituanie prévoit
désormais de renforcer leur coopération
militaire la coopération prend désormais
une forme très concrète avec
l'organisation d'exercices militaires
tout comme la Pologne la Lituanie a
construit un mur tout au long de ses
plus de 670 km avec la Biélorussie
avec de l'autre côté ce qu'elle
considère comme une menace plus de 4000
combattants du groupe de mercenaires
russe Wagner selon l'estimation
polonaise nous avons introduit un
certain nombre de mesures de systèmes
techniques nous avons déployé des
effectifs supplémentaires et nous avons
élevé la surveillance à la frontière au
niveau le plus haut
en cas de nouvelle provocation la
Pologne et la Lituanie n'exclut pas de
fermer totalement leur frontières avec
la Biélorussie